Vladimir Putin will lead Russia for
another six years he cruise to an
expected victory in yesterday's
presidential election winning nearly 77
percent of the vote it's his biggest
mandate yet for what will be his fourth
term Elizabeth Palmer is outside the
Kremlin in Moscow where Putin is
celebrating and tensions with the West
show no signs of easing Elizabeth fair
to say this was not a nail-biter good
morning of course the outcome of this
election was never in doubt so much so
that days ago workmen came to very close
to where I'm standing to build a massive
stage for Vladimir Putin's victory
speech he walked onto that stage late
last night plainly delighted by the size
of his landslide Russia's opposition
groups flagged several election
irregularities for example watch the
woman in the black dress stuffing the
ballot box but that wouldn't have
altered the result the fact is that the
majority of Russians willingly cast
ballots for the man they believe
restored stability to Russia of course
the Kremlin did pull out all the stops
to get out the vote including at the
polling station we visited setting up
free cancer screening blood tests after
his big win President Putin directly
addressed Britain's accusations that he
was behind the poisoning of the Russian
exile sergey skripnikov ages it was
rubbish she said but Putin's campaign
spokesman actually thanked Britain for
helping Putin win whenever Russia is
accused of something he said the people
gather round the centre of power which
is of course Vladimir Putin Gail right
Elizabeth Palmer reporting from Moscow